des coups de pédales sur vitaminée de la
bagarre dans les virages bienvenue sur
l'open de bmx et des clayes-sous-bois ce
dimanche 22 octobre plus de 400 biker se
sont donné rendez vous pour participer à
cette compétition amicale le niveau il
est régional mais aussi national on a
des pilotes qui viennent d'autres
départements et même d'autres régions on
a des pilotes
qui sont allés aux championnats du monde
qui ont fait les manches de coupe du
monde et du coup tout ça cette
compétition également permis aux bikers
de tester la toute nouvelle piste du
club inauguré début septembre plus d'un
million d'euros ont été investis pour
créer un tracé de 350 mètres homologué
par les instances fédérales
après quelques tours de piste premier
verdict à l'école franchement aléas
techniques allaient roulante les virages
sont propres donc on est au max on prend
comme on veut technique et pas trop
dangereuse les virages sont bien
compliqué à appréhender et et c'est ça
qui est marrant pour dompter les bosses
les 400 participants tous leurs propres
techniques par exemple sur dans les
virages ou sur les pas les parties plat
bien relancé et bien pousser sur tout ce
qui est enroulé tout ça mais bon soit
ses plus grosses
donc faut bien technique faut pas taper
faut être précis un repérage de la piste
qui pourrait faire la différence lors de
la prochaine édition 2010 8 l'événement
sera cette fois-ci officielle et
comptera pour le classement général